alright well III 2015 hasn't officially
started yet I think maybe fall out
already nip the honor of winning III I
don't ever [ __ ] chance another day I
don't even know where to start with this
one we have a whole sheet of things to
get through let's get let's just talk
right off the top shelf number one we
have a date November 10 2015 this year
with a my I'm not many months a handful
five close enough that i never have to
reschedule holiday time to make sure
that i have not wake up and it's there
is a free fallout game out tonight if
you want to just pick that up which
looks pretty rad we'll talk about that
in a little bit and it looks so good
let's let's roll it back to the start we
had a long presentation todd howard
showed off a bunch of concept art
nonsense and then they dove into the
game first thing we saw gentleman
looking into the mirror change in his
face it was so okay so you can play as
any skin color any any you can actually
fix their face to make it look like
whatever you want to look like um but
what she surprised me about this demo is
his wife is awkwardly standing over his
shoulder and then they swapped her in
and it turns out you can play as a woman
and fallout 4 so those rumors were
correct guessing absolutely um and this
is where you make your character and I
think you can name them as well yes and
this isn't 2077 so this is the yeah
before the war happens which is
something we've only seen little parts
of in the fallout universe and after
this is a sort of a they definitely
edited down the next couple of minutes
of the early part of the game before the
the war eventually came to us shores and
but yeah one of the things they showed
here as well was that you have a baby
and the baby's based off of almost like
GTA 5 online style yeah based on the
parents or conversations look at this no
more awkwardly zooming in on faces Lucy
yeah look at this I mean well there's
all girly zoom done that guy but no it's
just yeah it's fully voiced I think
that's another big thing is that all the
main characters are fully voiced and
while the facial animations still look a
little bit awkward um it yeah like his
eyes aren't quite as lifeless as they
were in Fallout New Vegas Kevin what do
you think about that
that aspect of it open world RPG games
fully voiced for a while and sort of
fall it's always been languishing a
little back around bethesda games have
been what do you think of that addition
yeah this is really exciting I mean
everything about the presentation was
was actually really getting me excited I
mean yeah sometimes maybe it's a little
awkward the way their lips move and and
that kind of thing or where the legs
move but I don't know like I'm it seems
like they've been actually paying
attention to the RPG world around them
and said hey you know what the witcher
is doing this cool stuff dragon age is
doing this cool stuff it's about time we
should probably live up to these ideas
and we saw some of this stuff in the
trailer they revealed just the number of
weeks ago and this all have hair flying
before the vault part and an interesting
thing that happens in this one which
does exist in fallout laura is the idea
of cryogenic stasis there was vault 0
which I think was part of a new vegas is
lower which was one of the votes in
which somebody who had been around
during the 2077 was able to come out
usually or the descendants who were like
great-great-grandchildren kind of
situation where as in this the character
you create the the mother or the father
or the wife of the husband have you come
out of the vault 111 as them again the
final survivor yeah alt and here we have
our little fallout 3 esque reveal of the
landscape as well as showing off and
it's not just brown yeah another great
thing I mean I mean it's there's color
there's there's still a sense of wonder
that's not just oh god everything's been
destroyed and scorched it's kind of like
you know like obviously the world got
destroyed and now nature's kind of
claiming it back slow yes and it looks
like a lot more nature than where we saw
in the west coast in terms of like just
even bushes and whatnot or what we see
in the in the DC area in fallout 3 he
also walked super nonchalantly for
somebody who's just seen all of his
friends and family he's looking all
right felt I know is gone they try to us
aunt it down be friends are dead they
pushed the idea of the third person in
Skyrim as well a lot in there you know I
really like maybe it'll work a little
bit better than this is bad i still look
at that green fonts yeah they something
i think i'll be adjusting that because i
intend me to play but i'm sure they'll
lets you and then yeah they show off
this is
I cosworth the robot which was the
families and de facto mechanical slave
so cool thing that is that they said
that they have recorded thousands of
names yes for the child as well yeah it
done and in terms of voice acting that's
really great yeah and then this is the
they were very quick to show that you
know these conversations like in Fallout
our quest that you can walk away from
come back there you can kill him if you
want you can continue on with the quest
which was one of the sort of the main
pillars of Bethesda's games as the
ability to just murder anyone you want
the idea that you had all the choice in
the world and to do what you wanted and
just like I wanted look at those
dialogue options yeah yeah yeah hold it
yeah a nice bit of a just in terms of
the voice acting dude I just can't
believe that a game of this scale is
going to have all this I like the way
it's also saying you okay it's almost
like which your star letting you know if
this is a dialogue option with a
different color that you're going to
dive into for yeah a little bit longer
but pushing on from this we then saw
later the i guess the gas station that
we saw in the trailer and a little doggy
Alexei you must be very happy I'm really
excited that you can command the dog it
sort of reminds me of the call of duty a
couple years back Riley I were you
carefully doesn't remind you too much of
rhyme no not too much I mean there's
sort of they look similar but not too
much but I they said context kari kamiya
better to [ __ ] some shot so it's not
quite controlling the dog but it still
looks like the dog is a major component
of you navigating the landscape and you
surviving which i think is I yes yes it
reminds me of the dog from the what is
that be able to know the ubisoft game
without the wall valiant hard way to go
pick things up and get them for you hmm
which looks like you can do a lot
earlier on the demo when they showed off
the the dog for the first time picking
up that wrench and that sort of area
that you had which we were speculating
was where you'd be building weapon parts
and building and your suit and whatnot
and then they showed off as well the
VATS is back we got your bets yes I
think a lot of people probably happy
about that and they showed off a lot of
Boston as well and this one they didn't
really allude to the scale of the world
but it's only
looked a lot more varied in terms of
color pilot disclaimer yeah I think
starting with all the concept I was very
smart thing to do as well because if
they could have just dropped you in and
you would've been like um well you know
this is it but with a concept i'll show
the real scale of the different kinds of
environments that's claws are back i
look so good to look at the way they
move like like a thing as a list of what
that fallout 3 block of mellow meet ya
we saw radroaches we saw rad scorpions
we saw mole rats on one of the concept
are things there was a there's a
protector Tron there I we saw mole rat
Queen looking at it's like a zombie ass
person feral guru that's 100 Jesus yeah
nope the variety game I guess they were
hammering home the idea of gameplay
variety which has always been a massive
pillar for the Fallout games but look at
this this [ __ ] just calling their
support and then you're in is like oh
I'm just gonna get up there at all yes
my gosh the first game that had for
flying this in their engine was the
killer teddy bear and the one of the
expansion packs for Skyrim it you fly
around so I guess they pulled that stuff
in check yes very much i'm actually i
don't think i've ever seen seen a press
conf it or they've shown this much
footage i think this is like going in
the in the record books or hall of fame
or v3 for most groundbreaking most
impactful economy mr. Sherman Duvall
look at this take that Megaton guys
don't know what like good on Bethesda
for waiting until the game was almost
done to hell yeah but are you good on
them but even then they weren't finished
they showed off that big gameplay
montage after waxing lyrical about the
game forever and then they pull you back
in and show you all this stuff like they
basic [ __ ] with the monster this is
hearthfire basically but yeah really
expanded its a you know think about
what's happened in the world since the
last fall I can come at games like rust
and and looking at like online survivor
games and not only can you build your
own house being your own community yeah
and defenses I mean it looks like
there's gonna be some kind of like
defense minigame here where you're like
you're gonna you're already attacked you
see the M there was a great tower
defense mod for skyrim there's someone
made and learn i would love if this was
a kind of run off of that hmm so in this
you can build your own house you can
the store make place to store your
pip-boy store your weapons you can make
terminals and then presumably probably
program them like the idea that you
could do all this for a house and then
also set up electrical things and you
had they said you had to collect water
and food for the people who your father
and all this is actually optional it's
like not necessarily part of the core of
all I fork experience and now you can
carry 40,000 pounds in your inventory if
they talked about in conference yet not
yet but I have to assume please help
raise it a little bit this is a plot
across to carry around and does all
these all these jerks artillery old
traps and if that wasn't enough then
they show off that you know powerful
going around collecting loose and then
building your own world you can also do
the same thing for our weapons and I
have any weapons but weapon components
yeah not even weapon components for
power armor her it's a look like this
nonsense it got really miss grizzy here
and they're like oh you don't have to do
any of this stuff he's like oh by the
way this is just there if you can't want
it it's all good look this is all stuff
we did we made this iphone a game on the
side oh yeah by the way like you can
play video games on the pip-boy hot and
listen to tapes on that's like a donkey
kong kind of game right there yeah and
then just when you thought there wasn't
enough of this madness they announced
that an actual physical pip-boy is also
big mate what a touch just stick your
phone in that yeah suddenly it's like oh
it's got a touch screen it's actually
more advanced than the real pit boys uh
who's picking with one of these up
absolutely i'll totally get why everyone
can't even with that pit boy I don't
even know where what I would do with it
where would I wear it what would I ever
all day every day can you imagine you
just think about all the people to walk
her in San Francisco what Apple watches
on you can be really all be walking
around boys all day long some next-level
nerdom yeah it's like he did listen to I
don't want to see the world on fire over
and over and over three dog you might be
able to get three doggone it all the
time can you oh just get his own radio
station yeah tvvv been laying low oh my
god ah yeah and then at the end they
dropped the bombshell am I guess 11 11
11 was all dated for Skyrim sure so 11
taunton
11 yeah the tenth of November 2015 will
be able to play fallout 4 like you for
that I actually cannot think of an e3
game announcement that had this much
impact I know it's like at the moment
afterwards really caught up in the
fervor yeah but Kevin can you think of
anything that's been quite as overtaking
is this no well seven or loss for work
it's finally happened oh my qualifying
observe it today's is better than the
Killzone 2 trailer oh yeah because we
can believe this this is actually
gameplay we looking at the only moon dog
that's hot like any kind of a similar
reaction was the the xbox one ps4 price
thing yes no I just just a moment of
everyone going no and that's basically
what happened in this war room when they
announced the release date I think this
was this butter this is bad yeah hundred
percent how many days until November 10
2015 148 days four hours 24 minutes and
36 seconds that's how long we have to
wait to play fallout 4 uh yeah I don't
think there's anything I say about
cryostasis now yes so that like tomorrow
it'll just be here let's all go into
cryostasis but I stay tuned to gamespot
com for continuing coverage of Fallout 4
for the next 148 days
you